foreign
starts off this hour in Nashville Hey
Kevin welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Mr Ramsey hey what's up
um so 23 years old and um ever since I
was about 17 I've been sports betting
and it's just gotten worse and worse and
worse and
I've I'm in GA now and I see a therapist
and
nothing really seems to work and I'm
just feeling really really defeated and
you know hopeless and I was just
wondering if you had any wisdom you
could share advice
I'm sorry man
that's a hard thing yeah it's it's the
worst thing that's ever happened to me
ever for
people in America that don't understand
the fastest the second fastest growing
Addiction in North America today is not
cocaine or fentanyl or prescription
drugs or alcohol it is
gambling online
fastest growing addiction second fastest
growing addiction first is porn
and we deal with we deal with these
numbers because we deal with people's
lives that are broken around their
finances all the time do this kind of
stuff so we've talked to over 30 years a
whole lot of people where Kevin is and
Kevin I'm not an addictions expert by
any stretch you know that right
absolutely yes sir all right so how long
have you been going to ga
um about three months and I've known
that I should have been going a lot
longer but absolutely not past just the
past you learned that in GA
all we do all we're worried about is
tomorrow is a new day right
yeah one baby step at a time right and
so how are you making all your meetings
are you going
yep I go twice a week um at two
different locations so and I also see a
therapist that specializes in it but for
some reason it's just it's just so hard
even with all of these things in place
so oh no it's not going to be easy
um it is very hard that's why we call it
an addiction and not a problem
right yeah if it was a problem you could
work through it it's an addiction and so
it's gonna it's it's got its claws deep
into your soul and you're having to work
you're having to pry them out a little
bit at a time so is your therapist
moving the needle
um definitely improvements I mean like I
said I've been gambling for five years
and I will go you know a few days or a
week or two now which if you told me a
year ago that could happen I would say
it's impossible
um I just haven't been able to fully
kick it like you said just the nature of
addiction I guess but it is the nature
of it but we have to obviously write a
new script for the future which is part
of why you're calling
um so what is the environment in which
you're are you online FanDuel or
whatever
yeah so it's online and I have you know
casinos close by that that take bets and
bookies and it's like you know every
everywhere I look I could gamble it's
just that's just how it feels so
okay what do you do for a living and I'm
tired of
yeah so um I work for the government and
um I have a college degree and I make 70
grand a year and that just makes me feel
even more worthless because no one my
age should be struggling I should be you
know doing the baby steps and here I am
just fueling a betting account with
every paycheck and you know that's just
like the worst part of it all are you
and are you in debt Kevin because of the
addiction
um yes thankfully not not too much but I
have about five thousand dollars worth
of credit card debt because just
recently they let you just put it on a
credit card now you don't even okay in
the last two weeks where did you place
your bets
um all online okay
so what do we do to cut that Source off
yeah so I I've excluded myself from um
like the ones that are like legalized
like you know in this like FanDuel and
stuff like that but the issue for me is
just that there's a thousand just online
offshore you know you can bet yeah
how do we turn your computer off is what
I'm asking for your phone yeah is that
your phone I guess dripping me stripping
me of electronics might actually yeah
well I mean for a while I'd be okay with
that because if you're drunk you can't
hang out in a bar right
yeah you're right and like I said not
only affected me financially it's every
relationship I have and my work it's
just I just feel so defeated yeah and
usually Kevin what we find too is that
the addiction is a symptom and so
dealing with that symptom is really
important like what Dave is saying but
also hopefully your therapist is getting
to the point of understanding what's
motivating that like right like were you
wanting that high what what that is
giving you is for a reason and so doing
that personal work and digging in to
those things which I hope hope your
therapist is doing to get to the root
cause is is huge you know I'd also plug
into a Celebration Recovery class in a
local church and get plugged in and
start walking this on the spiritual
angle as well that'd be my next thing uh
let's Circle back Rachel neither you nor
I know enough about addictions uh wish
John deloney was here today but to speak
intelligently into it there's a few
things we do know from having worked
with addicts over the years
um
you know one is you do need to plug into
a group and GA he called it was Gamblers
Anonymous is what that stands for it's
like Alcoholics Anonymous but for
gamblers is uh is incredible Celebrate
Recovery is an incredible Ministry with
a Christian uh purely Christian
Perspective and plugging into a good
church is a wonderful group and process
to plug into and certainly the
one-on-one therapist which is what he's
doing is there
um
MGA you need a a strong or in Celebrate
Recovery you don't want a strong sponsor
and the sponsor is the person who is
going to love you
um when you fall down but they're also
going to kick your butt and hold you
accountable and talk you off the ledge
so to speak metaphorically and uh you
know that that having those people in
your life matters and then what you said
before we went into the break is vital
that you dig into the root cause
because the gambling is uh the drinking
the gambling the cocaine use the
whatever the surface addiction is
there's always something under it that's
uh that's causing it and that is always
a a mental uh Health thing uh it's a
childhood thing it's a spiritual thing
and it may be all of those yeah
um it probably is all of those and so
you know as people of faith we also have
watched Our Lives be transformed by our
faith walk and by plugging into a good
church and setting up a new group of
friends that weren't the old friends I
mean you can't run around you're
drinking buddies anymore if you got a
drinking problem and so if uh Kevin's
running around with a bunch of guys that
are still running FanDuel every day and
all they're talking about is football
right and uh their fantasy league and
they're betting on this and they're
betting on that and so forth and
um
you know you gotta you got to change
your environment as well and then do set
something up take the stuff off the apps
off your phone or set the phone down for
a period of time or whatever it is
whatever it is you're using to access
that you've got to reset those things
but that won't work eventually you'll
find your way back to it if you don't
get down under the route and find it
yeah and and really dig into that and
that's some
anytime any of us go through and we all
do a a transformation at the Character
level at the spiritual level it's
painful yes people do it to get out of
debt they do it in their marriages they
do it recovering from their childhoods
but it's painful
there's nothing no pain quite like
emotional pain
but it's necessary for the change
because there is something too that uh
and again I wish John was here sitting
here because he's like the licensed
therapist but but too I'm like to the
spirit to the spiritual side which we
both have the same Faith walk
um there's a point in our human
condition that like when there's a
little bit of that surrender of like I
can't just keep pulling myself up by my
bootstraps over and I'm like there has
to be a transformation that occurs and I
think when you can pinpoint that whether
it's on a spiritual side
but also the emotional side right what
are the things going on where's like the
the anger the hurt the loan the things
in your life that could be part of the
thing that that's triggering this uh
what are events in your life that have
shaped who you are uh that you kind of
go back to these places of habit that
you don't even realize for protective
strategies I mean like we are just
complex people and I feel like more and
more we uncover that and money ends up
being a symptom for so much of that
that's why here on the Ramsey Show like
we talk about this stuff a lot not just
addiction but
um but the heart issues of what's going
on and our money is a tool in life that
ends up being affected because of it but
um but it's it but it can be a dark
really hard spot but I do just want to
applaud Kevin for even calling and
asking the question because uh you could
hear it let me tell you this Kevin I
will tell you that um I've seen a lot of
people be successful yes and walking
away from this uh we see a lot of
success uh there's other things that are
even harder to break I know this is hard
I'm not diminishing this but I mean uh
meth is and heroin are just dadgum the
percentages are very low that you get
out of that life but gambling people can
walk away from porn they can walk away
from they with help and with treatment
and the you know engaging in the process
and it is a spiritual walk it's popping
in my head so I'm just going to say it
um max lucado's notebook new book help
is here he was on yesterday talking
about it and uh it's about the Holy
Spirit and the power of the Holy Spirit
and Kevin I'm going to recommend that to
you and another one is Heinz feet and
high places that um is a very
interesting read when you're in the soup
and you are you're fighting out the soup
right now and we're here for you man you
called we'll talk to you anytime we love
you and um and you know we're not gonna
pull any punches with you we're going to
tell you the truth but um you're not
alone we're gonna walk with you but um
but also we're not going to tell you
that we have all the answers because we
certainly don't